[Music]
what I feel when I am dancing I feel
free I just feel confident I feel strong
I feel in control of Who I am
I knew this is what I wanted to do I
didn't want to do anything else a
budding baby
[Music]
this great big story was made possible
by a six sound mind sound body
[Music]
my name is Akira Armstrong and I'm the
CEO and founder a pretty big movement
which is a full-figured professional
dance company I started a pretty big
movement nine years ago and I felt that
there was a void in mainstream media
where it wasn't a platform for
plus-sized professional dancers I didn't
fit in even walking into auditions I
didn't feel like I belong
the typical expected body type is the
ballerinas you know the long legs and
long arms long torso it's upsetting that
society puts this label on dancers
because for me it's about the talent I
had booked this a major gig with Beyonce
I decided well let me audition for more
representation I auditioned for at least
five different agencies and they all
kept saying the same thing she's good
but we don't know how to market her and
I got tired of hearing that even though
I struggled with things it was my
passion it's something that I wanted to
do is something that I love and I kept
pushing and kept pushing and kept
pushing and it just got to a point where
I was like this is really what I want to
do we came up with the name pretty big
and from there I said I need a pack of
girls who know how to move who know how
to dance we have a range of young ladies
who
professional dancers they work hard to
prove themselves not only to me but also
to themselves one thing is that we do is
our pretty big movement workshop anybody
is welcome to come to our workshops I am
pretty big and I am powerful because I
feel nothing but loving this new power
circles and that portion of the workshop
becomes very emotional we have had
people say I beat divorce I beat suicide
I was a rape victim I beat cancer so I
wasn't gonna let this fight they just
kind enough to just spill it all out the
misconceptions that people have about
plus-sized women we are lazy we have low
self-esteem we don't care about our
appearance we are non-existent and we
exist this is who I am
plus-size and fabulous
[Music]